Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich habe gehört Chuck Norris ist gestorben.
Die Berichte über seinen Tod sind stark übertrieben.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 548 vom 20. März 2026 und seht es uns nach.
Wir haben eine kurze Unterbrechung im Programm gehabt, denn die letzte Sendung war vom 27.
Februar und seitdem kam es irgendwie nicht dazu.
Termine, Termine, Termine, aber immerhin sind wir jetzt wieder auf dem selben breiten Grad.
Mit einer langen Sendung.
Einer langen Sendung. Das klingt ja jetzt nicht besonders optimistisch.
Ja, eine lange Sendung, Logbuch Netzpolitik ist selten was Gutes.
Also heißt nichts Gutes.
Du weißt, was ich weile.
So viel zu den Erwartungshaltungen. Ihr könnt es euch schon mal gemütlich machen.
Du kannst schon mal direkt den Finger hier zum Gute-Nachricht-Dschingel machen.
Ja?
Ja.
Jetzt schon. Surprise, Motherfucker,
Also, okay Also der Finger Der Finger Der Finger ist jetzt schon mal am richtigen
Ort Soll ich schon loslegen oder haben wir noch irgendwas zu berichten?
Ähm, haben wir noch irgendwas zu berichten?
Irgendwas? Ich weiß.
Aus dem persönlichen Kontext heraus. Ich bin aufgeregt. Du bist aufgeregt.
Ich bin aufgeregt.
Okay, wegen der Sendung. Oder generell einfach.
Sendung kann. In der Sendung Logbuch Netzpolitik habe ich Routine.
Das ist jetzt die 548. Ein paar waren ohne mich, aber meine 500 werde ich schon so gemacht haben.
Das werde ich gleich mal überprüfen.
Das kann ich inzwischen. Also sagen wir mal, inzwischen bin ich nicht mehr ganz
so aufgeregt. Also ich habe schon, morgen stehe ich auf mit Lampenfieber.
Aber kriege ich hinter mich Gebracht Was ich nicht hinkriege Ist Wenn ich irgendwie
bei diesem Funfacts Gefragt werde, ob ich da auch mal was mitmache Und mir garantiert wird,
dass ich So ein Side-Act bin und dann steht auf einmal,
Funfacts mit Linus Neumann in diesem Verkaufsding Damit komme ich nicht zurecht Okay.
Das verstehe ich Also man erwartet mehr von dir Das ist Druck.
Das ist Pressure hier. Das ist die ganze Leistungsdruck, der ja auf mir landet.
Und vor allem das habe ich ja noch nie gemacht. Das kann ja auch gar nicht.
Und jetzt muss ich das lernen bis dahin.
Okay, also ich kann dich beruhigen, du hast bis dato an 509 der Sendung teilgenommen.
509?
Oh krass, haben wir das öfter?
Achso, ich war ja einige Zeiten mal weg.
So, 509. Okay, aber dann hätten wir ja mal meine 500. Sendung feiern können.
Tja, das hätten wir machen können, wenn wir das gewusst hätten,
aber haben wir übersehen.
Tja, aber ich habe meine 500er auch nicht gefeiert, aber wir haben unsere gefeiert.
Ja, das ist übrigens auch schon etwas länger her wieder, wir könnten mal wieder,
aber Eselts Albtraum, hier, Elenos, hatte sich an mich gewendet und hatte so
ein Foto, was ich ihr geschickt hatte von den beiden,
die am Anfang gejodelt haben.
Ja.
Und meinte so, habt ihr noch mehr von den Bildern? Und dann hab ich so gedacht,
ja, bestimmt hab ich bestimmt...
Das Bild hatte ich selber irgendwie so aus Social Media, wahrscheinlich von Mastodon oder so.
Ich glaube von Ralf Stockmann geklaut, der das gepostet hat.
Da musste ich dann auch sagen, so ja, du, da war ich gar nicht, hab ich geklaut.
Wenn ihr da wart und vielleicht noch Bilder habt, würden wir uns glaube ich
über eine Mail freuen oder Elenos will sich freuen, Eseles Albtraum würden sich freuen.
Das gilt im Übrigen nicht nur für den Act, sondern für das ganze Event.
Ich hab nämlich dann mal in mein Archiv geschaut fürs Gestint. Ich hab gar keinen.
Ich hab nur Bilder von dem Autounfall, den du dann nachgebaut hast.
Weißt du noch? Diese Autobubser, die uns da verarscht haben.
Also, Autounfall. Die R-Quotes sind aber jetzt in Stadtteilgröße.
Will man nicht meinen, ey.
Ich hab ihn nur touchiert. Nee, der ist geliebt.
5000 Euro. Ey, was für eine...
Echt, ey.
Das hast du davon, wenn du nach West-Berlin fährst, ja? Wo die Leute irgendwie
geputzte Autos haben und sowas.
Da fahren wir nicht wieder hin.
Das war eine schlechte Erfahrung. Mein Autopo war hier, der ist gerade.
Nichts war da. Nichts.
Nein, und ich hab's auch gesagt.
Aber so ist es halt. Selbst wenn du mal was sagst, die Leute glauben es halt nicht immer.
Ja, da werd ich nie mit zurechtkommen.
Das ist schlimm für dich, ich weiß. Aber da war nichts.
Mann, ey, ich hab doch tausend Fotos. Die hätte ich Eleanor Schinke,
weiß nicht, wie oft ich da Mikroskop-Makro-Funktion vom iPhone,
mehr Licht hier, ein Bild von nichts.
Wenn wir Chuck Norris dabei gehabt hätten, ja, dann wäre das sicherlich anders gelaufen.
Chuck Norris hätte da wenigstens mal eine Macke in das Auto gehauen.
Ja, eben.
Dann hast du mal einen Grund zu heulen, dann hast du auch einen Versicherungsfall.
Wie, das ist eine Macke?
Das soll eine Macke sein? Das ist doch keine Macke. Das ist eine Macke.
Ob er das besser gefunden hätte? Ich meine, hätte der Typ für die 5000 Euro
in der Reparaturwerkstatt auf jeden Fall was zu tun gehabt.
Waren 5.000 Euro, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Also wenn ich...
Also, wenn ich sowas, also für das Geld hätten wir auf jeden Fall noch ein paar
Scheiben einschlagen können.
Da muss man echt sagen, so, komm, ey, dann, was kostet das 5000?
Na komm, dann brechen wir jetzt noch hier irgendwas ab oder so.
Ey, dann pissen wir noch auf den Ledersitz oder so.
Die Reifen sind eh nicht mehr gut.
Ja, oder dann hauen wir noch, irgendwo stechen wir noch einen Reifen ein oder
irgendwas. Aber nichts.
Das war's.
Das war ja, du hast ja nichts.
Tja, was ist das? Heutzutage ist immer viel Lärm um nichts.
Das ist, äh, die Realität. Kommen wir zu den guten Nachrichten? Ja?
Ja.
Gut.
Die freiwillige Chat-Kontrolle wurde nicht verlängert. Völlig überraschend.
Es handelt sich um die Ausnahmeregelung von der E-Privacy-Verordnung,
die Meta, Google und Microsoft überhaupt rechtlich ermöglicht hat,
freiwillig ohne dazu gezwungen zu werden,
die Chats oder die Inhalte von Nachrichten nach CSAM zu untersuchen. CSAM,
Child Sexually Abused Material und das wurde ja jahrelang immer diese E-Privacy
Ausnahme, das haben sie immer genommen und haben gesagt wir müssen jetzt die Chat-Kontrolle,
verabschieden weil die E-Privacy Richtlinien Ausnahme da, die die läuft aus,
und die Kommission will das verlängern, dann haben sie mit EU-Parlament und
Rat verhandelt, dass es jetzt gescheitert und ab dem 4.
April ist das wieder nicht mehr erlaubt.
Und das finde ich natürlich, also das ist schon sehr lustig.
Also sehr schön, ja, dass man hier auf,
sinnvolle Überlegungen kommt. So, jetzt müssen wir natürlich viele Leute,
die zum ersten Mal, die nicht 548 Folgen dabei waren oder 509 wie ich,
nochmal kurz erklären, warum ist das eine schlechte Idee.
Warum eigentlich, Linus?
Soll ich das nochmal erklären? Also, du hast...
Wenn du in dieser Menge Daten und Kommunikationen überwachst und das in diesem
Fall dann auch automatisiert,
hast du auch bei sehr geringen Fehlerquoten immer noch eine horrende Menge an False Positives.
Ein Fall, den wir hier vor einiger Zeit behandelt hatten, war ein Mann,
der auf Aufforderung eines Arztes an Selbingen ein Bild von seinem Kind geschickt hatte,
das eine Verletzung am Unterleib hatte.
Und daraufhin ging der Filter an und der Mann wurde lebenslang von Google gebannt. Google-Verbot.
Mit der Chat-Kontrolle, die als Gesetzesvorschlag ja vorangetrieben wird,
wäre nicht nur die Konsequenz, dass Google die sperrt oder was auch immer macht,
sondern auch noch eine automatisierte Meldung an Polizeibehörden ergehen soll.
Und das Ganze auch bei verschlüsselten Messengers passieren soll.
Und damit hättest du eine Situation, wo du mit deinem verschlüsselten Messenger
irgendwie kommunizierst und ein Scan dieser verschlüsselten Inhalte mittels
einer KI stattfindet vor bzw.
Nach der Verschlüsselung. Also hast du eine KI-Überwachung deiner Kommunikationsinhalte
mit automatisierter Ausleitung an die Polizei.
Und das ist nun wirklich eine sehr schlechte Idee.
Vor allem, wenn man das technisch zu Ende denkt, kannst du dann sagen...
Den Messenger, da könntest du es ja auch immer noch rauspatchen.
Also angenommen, mir würde jetzt, also nehmen wir Signal als Beispiel,
einer der verbreiteteren, verschlüsselten Messenger.
Angenommen, Signal würde gezwungen, das zu tun, irgendeine KI-Überwachung da
einzubauen. Wobei, wenn ich mir den Vortrag von Udbaf und Meredith beim Kongress
anschaue, würde ich vermuten, die würden sich da wahrscheinlich nicht zuzwingen lassen.
Angenommen, sie würden es und angenommen, sie täten es, dann könntest du es ja wieder rauspatchen.
Das ist ja eine Open-Source-Software. Das heißt, was,
Die logische Konsequenz wäre, dass irgendwann auf den Plattformen,
auf den Geräten zu verankern.
Ja, dass du nämlich sagst, nee, wir wissen ja, dass Signal keine vernünftige
Überwachungs- KI in ihren verschlüsselten Messenger bauen, also bauen wir das
am Ende in iOS oder Android ein.
Eine wirklich sehr schlechte Idee,
weil sie erstens schlechte Erkennungsquoten hat und bei diesen schlechten Erkennungsquoten
Eben Unmengen an falschen Verdächtigungen und dann irgendwie automatisch an die Polizei.
Das war wirklich ein ernsthaftes Problem.
Noch dazu, die tatsächlich kriminellen Menschen, die würden ja auch um so etwas
wissen, das heißt die weichen natürlich sehr schnell aus auf Systeme,
wo sie dieser Überwachung entgehen würden,
beispielsweise einfach ordentliche, Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Systeme, wie wir sie jetzt haben.
Also wieder eine Massenüberwachung, die genau die Menschen trifft und nicht die Kriminellen.
Wie jede Massenüberwachung eigentlich nur dazu geeignet ist,
die Kriminellen dahin zu lenken, sich vor ihr zu schützen,
während die unbescholtenen Bürger ja nichts zu verbergen haben und dann dieser
massenhaften Überwachung ausgesetzt sind.
Ja, war schön.
Deswegen ist das scheiße Genau.
Aber dass sie jetzt hier diese Ausnahme Gekippt haben Das muss ich echt sagen,
das ist Überraschung Naja.
Sie wurde ja nicht verlängert Weil sie hätte jetzt verlängert werden Müssen,
wenn ich das richtig sehe Ja.
Die ist immer nur für ein Jahr.
Und dazu gab es halt nicht die notwendige Mehrheit, das zu verlängern,
Und schon haben wir eine gute Nachricht. So einfach geht das?
Snap mit den Fingern. Zack, bumm.
Zack, schon gibt es was Gutes.
Zack, bumm.
Da werden die Leute im Iran sich freuen, dass es auch eine gute Nachricht gibt.
Da wollten wir ja nicht drüber reden.
Ja, also wenn wir damit anfangen, dann wird die sehr zu lang.
Wir könnten auch über Überraschungen und Atombomben mit der japanischen Premierministerin sprechen.
Nicht mehr Trump als nötig.
Das war jetzt schon zu viel. Es gibt in diesem Bereich, also gestern kam eine,
Eilmeldung, glaube ich war das sogar.
Da ist mir echt die Spucke weggeblieben. Es gibt eine Schauspielerin mit dem
Namen Colleen Fernandez,
die seit vielen Jahren so eine der lauteren Stimmen und engagierteren Stimmen gegen Deepfake,
Pornografie ist, insbesondere unter ihrem Namen, aber das Thema auch entsprechend
politisch aktivistisch behandelt.
Deepfake Pornos, ich glaube wir haben vor einiger Zeit schon darüber gesprochen.
Deepfake kennt man, Porno hat man schon mal davon gehört.
Die beiden zusammen kann man sich vorstellen, was das ist. Das zu verbreiten von Menschen,
ist natürlich eine sehr schwere.
Erniedrigung und Entwürdigung und die hat die Coline Fernandes an unterschiedlichen
Stellen sehr häufig erfahren.
Und Ende 2025, wie jetzt bekannt wurde, hat sie dann eben Anzeige erstattet
gegen ihren inzwischen Ex-Mann Christian Ulmen, den man wahrscheinlich kennt.
Unter anderem Tatort-Kommissar und hat aber irgendwie, ich weiß nicht,
ich hab eher früher so Sachen geguckt, wie Mein neuer Freund und so,
und da hat er echt witzige Sachen gemacht, ja, aber ist ein,
denke ich, relativ bekannter,
deutscher Schauspieler, ich glaub irgendwo bei Viva oder MTV oder irgendein
Quatsch, da angefangen Viva-Moderator Viva-Moderator, ja, das hab ich immer
nicht geguckt, der hat mir Kirre gemacht der hat,
also wirklich eine völlig absurde also es kann man auch wirklich,
also es ist einfach nur krank, was der gemacht hat und also irgendwie,
Identitätsdiebstahl, der hat gefälschte Profile auf LinkedIn unter ihrem Namen
unterhalten und dann irgendwelche Leute angeschrieben und irgendwie um die 30
Online-Affären unter ihrem Namen gehabt und also wirklich,
also fürchterlich,
erstens für sie, ich will gar nicht wissen, wie das jetzt also überhaupt,
dass sowas passiert und dass du dann auch noch feststellst, dass dein Ehemann über Jahre.
Gleichzeitig auch fürchterlich, was der Mann für eine völlige Krankheit hat,
mit der der sich ja jetzt eigentlich alles ruiniert. Alles ruiniert, ne? Ähm.
Absolut, also wirklich absolut krank, ja.
Und auch wirklich nicht schön zu lesen, er war einfach nur krank.
So, warum behandeln wir das?
Weil natürlich das Thema jetzt wirklich dann durch den Spiegel,
Spiegelrecherche ordentlich seziert, recherchiert, ein bisschen,
also sag ich mal, auf dem Detailgrad, der unangenehm ist, dem aber auch notwendig.
Und Bundesjustizministerin Hubig, natürlich, was passiert,
hat dann jetzt fürs Frühjahr das digitale Gewaltschutzgesetz nochmal angekündigt,
mit dem Ziel, die Strafbarkeitslücken bei Deepfake-Pornos zu schließen und die
Accounts von den Tätern per Gericht sperrbar zu machen.
Und im Zivilverfahren bessere Auskunftsrechte zu schaffen.
Wenn man sowas High-Level formuliert, klingt das immer erstmal ganz sinnvoll,
aber ich glaube Auskunftsrechte im Zivilverfahren, da lauert auf der anderen
Seite natürlich auch wieder sofort,
der Missbrauch von oder die missbrüchliche Anwendung in anderen Verfahren.
Schauen wir mal, wie das ausformuliert wird.
Gleichzeitig glaube ich, wahrscheinlich hat sie das auch auf Twitter bekannt
gegeben, der primären Verteilplattform für Deepfake,
Pornos und so. Weiß ich nicht, ob sie das gemacht hat. Ich wollte nur darauf
hinweisen, dass eigentlich alle Politiker diese Plattform ja noch nutzen.
Ja.
Als Kontext muss man auch sagen, es werden irgendwie sehr viel weniger Deepfake-Pornos
von Männern gemacht und wenn Männer dabei sind, dann sind sie nicht in der Hauptdarsteller.
Das heißt, wir haben hier nicht nur sowieso ein ekelhaftes Phänomen,
sondern auch noch eins, was ganz klar eine sexistische Komponente auch nochmal hat.
Ja, also vor allem auch antifeministische.
Also völlig daneben. Ich denke, das ist auch sinnvoll,
hier vernünftige gesetzliche Regelungen zu finden, die dafür angemessen hohe Strafen ermöglichen.
Man muss halt schauen die Möglichkeit Accounts zu de-anonymisieren und Auskunftsrechte
für Zivilverfahren es gibt eigentlich nur,
es gibt ein sehr bekanntes in Anführungszeichen Zivilverfahren wo Auskunftsrechte
massenhaft verwendet werden das sind Abmahnungen bei File-Sharing also ich will
nur sagen das lässt sich halt potenziell industrialisieren,
ich bin kein Jurist aber da muss man aufpassen, dass man hier vernünftige,
und zielgerichtete Regelungen findet.
Naheliegend wäre natürlich zu sagen, okay, man beschränkt das auf Deepfake-Verbreitung,
aber wir wissen auch, dass dann bei dem nächsten Gesetz dann einfach in dem
Paragrafen noch zwei, drei andere Straftatbestände hinzugefügt werden.
Aber auf jeden Fall ist auch klar, dass wir den Status quo, wie er jetzt grassiert
in den sozialen Medien, hier mit Grog, Zieh mal aus und sowas,
dass man das so auf gar keinen Fall tolerieren kann und dass da was passieren muss.
Definitiv.
Also insbesondere jetzt nochmal durch diese Eskalation durch die KI-Generatoren,
die das auch wirklich echt auf elf drehen.
Also das war vorher schon problematisch, aber mittlerweile ist es halt einfach
durch diese niedrigen, quasi nicht vorhandenen Kosten zu einem super Problem geworden.
Wird sich sicherlich auch nicht vollständig einfangen lassen,
aber es ist zumindest angemessen, das dann auch entsprechend rechtlich zu verfolgen.
Wir hatten hier vor einigen Folgen auch ein bisschen über die Rolle von GROC,
dieser KI von Elon Musk, auch gesprochen,
dass ein besonderes Problem natürlich ist, dass sie das überhaupt ermöglicht.
Und dass dann die rechtliche Frage so war, dass die GROC-Leute gesagt haben, ja nee,
also wenn die Leute was Illegales machen, waren es ja immer noch die Leute,
Die haben ja ein illegales Prompt gegeben und da würde ich sagen,
will ich auf jeden Fall mal das rechtlich schon ein bisschen umkehren und sagen, nee, nee,
pass auf, also wenn du das nicht nur...
Versehentlich mal jemand schafft, deine Sperren zu umgehen, sondern du das industrialisierst,
memifizierst und dich daran erfreust, dass alle das machen,
dann bist du Täter und eventuell, also sicherlich mit einer noch höheren Schuld
beladen als die Menschen,
die diese Prompts in einem schlechten Moment vielleicht auch einfach mal nur abgesetzt haben.
Also ich spreche jetzt nicht von sowas, was Christian Ulm gemacht hat,
aber du konntest ja auch irgendwie, was weiß ich, ist ein Bild und dann sagst
du, ey, guck mal alle in Unterwäsche oder so.
Und das ist, wenn da irgendwie Donald Trump und sonst was ist,
dann ist das unter Umständen, kann das ja auch mal lustig sein.
Ja, es wird aber in der Regel nicht mit Donald Trump gemacht,
sondern mit, weiß ich nicht, linken AktivistInnen in der Regel dann oder so.
Ja, schauen wir mal, was sie sich dagegen einfallen lassen. Ich bin mir sicher,
es wird Handwerk nicht richtig gelungen sein, da müssen wir überhaupt nichts dran kritisieren.
Also bei der Exzellenz, die die Bundesregierung bisher auf den Tisch gelegt hat, denke ich auch.
Könnte man den Kulturstaatsminister fragen, ob der nur eine gute Idee hat.
Das ist ja auch sehr kreativ. Ich denke, da können wir auch einfach mal vier
Wochen Pause machen. Da geht alles total supi ab.
Aber diese Story, ey Mann, die arme Frau Fernandes, ja, also was für eine unglaubliche,
was für ein Horror, absoluter Horror, also ganz, ganz,
und wenn du findest, du siehst ja dann auch die Artikel, ne,
wenn die Related, seit wie vielen Jahren die dieses Thema besetzt, ja.
Und die Lösung ist irgendwie next door.
Next mattress. Ja.
Ja, ja. Gut. Was macht, unter der Abteilung, was kann man mit AI eigentlich alles so machen?
Kann man auch was Vernünftiges mitmachen vielleicht?
Nämlich hacken. Hacken geht supi.
Da gibt es eine Bude, die heißt Codewell.
Ich würde sagen Codewell.
Code Wall, Entschuldigung, Code Wall, sorry, nicht Code Wall.
Vielleicht kodieren sie auch gut, aber so haben sie sich nicht genannt, Code Wall, sorry.
Die haben sich so ein automatisiertes Hacker-Tool zusammengebaut,
so mit den gängigen Instrumenten, die einem jetzt ja ohne weiteres zur Verfügung stellen.
Und haben also diesen Agenten mal damit beauftragt, auch mal zu gucken,
ob nicht im Internet irgendwie was
zu holen ist und haben dann mal bei der Beraterfirma McKinsey angeklopft.
Großes Unternehmen, weltweit tätig, man kennt es.
Extrem gut beleumdet, überall beliebt.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall schon mal von gehört.
Ja, und was hat dieses Tool dann gemacht? Dieses Tool war quasi ohne,
also sie haben es mit nichts gepreppt.
Sie haben es einfach mal nur so auf McKinsey angesetzt. Ich glaube,
es gab vorher sogar noch so einen Entscheidungsdialog, wo sie so gefragt haben,
wo könnte man denn mal anklopfen und da kam dann wohl McKinsey auch schon als
Vorschlag bei raus, warum auch immer.
Auf jeden Fall hat sich dann dieser AI-Agent mal genauer angeschaut,
wie es denn so mit dieser Online-Infrastruktur aussieht, die McKinsey so meint zu haben.
Und siehe da, die gesamte Dokumentation ihrer API, mit der sie so im Internet
hängen, mit ihren Systemen, die war auch verfügbar.
Hat sich die AI dann schön durchgelesen, mal durchanalysiert und festgestellt,
okay, von den gut 200 Endpoints, die da sind, sind so gut 10% nicht durch Zugangsregeln geschützt.
Und dann hat die AI auch gleich angefangen, sich das doch mal genauer anzuschauen
und ist da so iterativ vorgegangen und hat sich das also mal so angeklopft und
geschaut, was spuckt denn das System raus.
Naja, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, relativ schnell, also dieser ganze Prozess hat
zwei Stunden gedauert und auf einmal war alles offen.
SQL-Injections wurden gefunden, mit pfiffigen Tricks wurde also dieses System
ausgehebelt und auf einmal lag alles da.
Und was man dann offengelegt hat, war so deren Intranet, was halt nicht nur
irgendwie eine Datenbank war, sondern selber auch ein AI-System.
Stellt sich raus, dass sie das also auf breiter Ebene intern zum Einsatz bringen
und dort lag dann irgendwie alles rum.
46,5 Millionen Chatnachrichten, insgesamt 728.000 Dateien, also auch vertrauliches Zeug dabei,
57.000 Nutzerkonten und mehr als noch das, also auch diese ganzen Dokumente, interne Studien,
also sozusagen einmal alles.
Das gesamte Wissen dieses Unternehmens, was sich in Daten abbildet,
über AI-Chatboards zugreifbar, die also offensichtlich von allen Mitarbeitern
auf diese Art und Weise auch mit genutzt wird.
Und, aber dabei blieb es gar nicht mal, auch die ganzen Prompts,
die ganzen System-Prompts, die Pre-Prompts, die in diesem System abgelegt sind,
um dann das Verhalten dieser ganzen Chatbots, mit denen man dann agiert,
die das bestimmen, waren halt auch offen und zwar nicht nur lesbar,
sondern auch schreibbar.
Mit anderen Worten, dieses System hätte nach zwei Stunden den gesamten Modus
Operandi von McKinsey quasi umstellen können.
Ich meine, da hätte man auch mal was Gutes tun können für die Welt.
Ja, also vielleicht, ja nee, guck mal nicht immer nur aufs Geld,
schau doch mal, dass da irgendwie auch sozial was da rauskommt.
Spätestens wenn McKinsey empfiehlt, mehr Leute einzustellen,
statt welche rauszuwerfen, wäre die Leute dann aber auch misstrauisch geworden.
Da muss ein Fehler sein.
Also das ist sozusagen also da waren halt viele klassische Fehler gemacht worden,
aber das Kernproblem jetzt an dieser Stelle ist während es früher,
sagen wir mal ausführliche Hacker-Skills brauchte, brauchst jetzt die zwar auch
noch in gewisser Hinsicht, aber auch vieles davon lässt sich jetzt auch schon,
automatisieren und wenn ich das richtig sehe,
beflügelt von dieser Meldung, habt ihr dann auch gleich zugeschlagen Ja.
Ich will aber erst kurz noch ein bisschen, also so kurz diesen Fall einordnen.
Also, was...
Wie wird so ein Chatbot gebaut?
Die Architektur. Also du hast...
Was ist jetzt der, der jetzt hier angegriffen hat? Oder das,
was da innerhalb von McKinsey läuft? Oder generell?
Was, warum, du hast gesagt, da gab es eine API und dann gab es eine SQL-Injection.
Das war, also was das Ding, was du da gesehen hast, ist im Prinzip eine Web-App.
Also eine Web-Applikation, wie du sie schreibst, die die APIs bereitstellt,
die ein Front-Interface hat im Frontend für die Userin, wo dann irgendwie drin
steht, hier kannst was hintippen und wenn ich Enter drücke, dann wird das an die API geschickt. Und,
Diese, also ein Mapping zwischen, die API hat 200 Endpunkte,
das heißt in dem Fall 200 unterschiedliche Arten, wie man mit ihr interagieren kann.
Das eine ist zum Beispiel, ich bin ein neuer Nutzer und ich möchte mich anmelden
oder hier ist mein Passwort und ich bin jetzt angemeldet.
All das ist immer ein API-Endpunkt, also eine Art, wie man da hinschreiben kann
und dann ist natürlich auch so, ich habe eine authentifizierte Session und zwar
in dem Chat 3 möchte ich jetzt folgende Nachricht schicken, das ist alles immer,
ein Endpunkt, ich möchte ein Setting ändern, das ist auch ein Endpunkt,
da kannst du wahrscheinlich dann mehrere Settings angeben oder so, so ist eine API.
Konfiguriert oder strukturiert. Und jetzt gibt es natürlich an so einer API,
das war das, was du gerade sagtest, 22 waren unauthenticated,
obwohl sie es sein mussten.
Das heißt, du konntest etwas tun, wozu du eigentlich in irgendeiner Weise eine
Authentifizierung gebraucht hättest.
Angemeldete Nutzerin sein oder vielleicht sogar angemeldete Administratorin sein.
Habe ich jetzt eine Session als User? Habe ich eine Session am Backend als Admin?
Tür ohne Schluss.
Das ist aber ein sehr, sehr häufiger Fehler bei komplexeren APIs,
dass sie nicht sauber durchchecken, dass Mapping aus der Rolle,
Authentisierung ist eine Sache, dann kommt ja auch noch Autorisierung.
Das heißt, du bist angemeldet, wunderbar, du bist der Tim, du willst jetzt hier
einen administrativen Befehl ausführen, deine Rolle erlaubt das aber nicht, weil du bist ja User.
Das erste ist, wer bist du, das zweite ist, was darfst du.
Genau, und das passiert sehr häufig.
Also es ist eine Schwachstelle, die man häufig findet und, das ist das Entscheidende,
die hat überhaupt nichts zu tun mit der KI.
Das ist also, diese Schwachstelle ist in dem Frontend, was die gebastelt haben,
dass am Ende nämlich von der Architektur hast du dann die Web-App,
da kann man sich anmelden, da kann man was hinschicken und irgendwo gibt es
dann eben auch die so und so viel API-Endpunkte, die sagen, den Inhalt nehme
ich jetzt, gib den an ein LLM,
krieg die Antwort und gib die zurück.
Da war jetzt offenbar einer dieser Endpunkte, hatte eine SQL-Injection.
SQL-Injection, eine der wunderschönsten Schwachstellen, auch immer wieder sehr schön zu erklären.
Wenn man mit einer Datenbank spricht, dann spricht man eine bestimmte Sprache.
In diesem Fall die Structured Query Language, also eine Datenbanksprache.
SQL ist besonders schön, weil es immer so ein bisschen schlechtes Englisch eigentlich
ist Select so und so ja, so wie bei uns Select Sternchen from Bobby Drop Table.
Und jetzt das Spannende daran ist und das ist wirklich warum SQL-Schwachstellen
so schön sind um Security zu erläutern,
wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sage, suche in der Tabelle Nutzer nach dem Nutzer Tim. Na?
Das wäre jetzt etwas, was man im Zweifelsfall macht, wenn jemand sich als Tim anmeldet.
Dann schickt da jemand hin. Als wäre möchtest du dich anmelden? Ja, als Tim. Okay.
Suche in der Datenbank. Und dann sagt er wirklich, select User from table users where name equals Tim.
So, das Tim, das war ja jetzt aber kontrolliert von...
Von dem Angreifer oder von dem Nutzer. Was ist denn jetzt, wenn der Nutzer nicht
Tim heißt, sondern Tim-Ausführungszeichen oben, Semikolon, lösche alles.
Das wäre dann immer noch, wenn man das einfach aneinander packt,
ein für die Datenbank valider Befehl, den sie auch ausführen würde.
Und man muss also es ist offensichtlich nicht so einfach, kriegen ja die ganze
Zeit Leute nicht hin man muss immer aufpassen, dass das was man an User Generated
Input in einen anderen Kontext gibt, also an eine Datenbank,
dass das dort in irgendeiner Weise sichergestellt wird, dass nicht der wahre
Datenbankbefehl, den ich eigentlich beabsichtige,
in seinem Kontext verändert wird und da gibt es eben diesen klassischen X-Case,
die jetzt fällt mir die Nummer nicht ein, wo die Schule bei der Mutter anruft und sagt,
ja, wir wollten mal fragen, ob der Sohn denn wirklich Anführungszeichen oben
Semikolon Droptable Students heißt und oder ob er nicht vielleicht eine SQL-Injection gemacht hat.
Also quasi diese Kontextänderungen.
So funktioniert, darauf basieren relativ viele,
Schwachstellen in der IT?
Exploits of a Mamm. 327.
327, musst du verlinken. Und die Gegenmaßnahme ist, dass man dann eben jeweils die Charaktere,
also die, was weiß ich, Semikolon und so weiter, die eine besondere Bedeutung
in der Sprache haben, in die du gerade reinpipest, dass du aufpasst,
dass du die escapest oder sicherstellst,
dass eben nicht jemand einfach die Datenbanksprache spricht in einem Feld,
das die Datenbank auch interpretiert.
Das war hier also die zweite klassische, wirklich ganz, ganz klassische Web-App-Schwachstelle,
so aus den frühen 90ern oder so, als das erfunden wurde.
Und.
Der, insofern hat dieser Scanner von dieser Firma nur, nur in Anführungszeichen
verhältnismäßig klassische Web-Schwachstellen gefunden.
Damit ist er dann, auch das ist häufig der Fall, bei einer schlecht gehärteten
Web-App, hat er dann die Möglichkeit gehabt, also erstmal Blinddaten zu extrahieren.
Also er konnte Daten rauskriegen, aber musste halt ins Blinde stochern,
bis er eine richtige Daten zurückbekommen hat. 15 Iterationen hat er gebraucht.
Und dann konnte er eben, hat der Schreibzugriff auf Dateien in dem Web-Root
und konnte dann die Web-App selber verändern und damit eben die AI-Write-Instructions, ne?
Und damit hätte dann eben quasi äh der, die die KI auch anders antworten lassen, ne?
So irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, und Antworten übrigens immer genau das Gegenteil
von dem, was richtig ist oder so, ne? So kam.
Man durch diesen Angriff auch auf die Chat-Messages, die nämlich diese Web-App
zum Loggen irgendwo hingeschrieben hat.
Und die Dateien und Dokumente waren im Zweifelsfall Sachen, die Leute da hochgeladen haben.
Und die 57.000 User-Accounts würde ich jetzt mal aus der hohlen Hand schätzen,
ist wahrscheinlich die aktuelle Anzahl Angestellter bei McKinsey,
weil die das Ding wahrscheinlich an die Entra-ID angebunden hatten.
Jedenfalls, natürlich war das bei uns in der Firma auch Thema,
ja, und dann sagte unser CEO so, ja, der war früher bei McKinsey,
sagte, ja, hier, sowas sollten wir auch mal machen, ja, und dann hat René,
mein Kollege, gesagt, achso, ja, okay, wenn, dann mach ich das jetzt halt, ne, und hat, ähm,
sich von einer anderen großen Firma.
Den Chatbot angeschaut und da gibt's wieder eine sehr ähnliche Geschichte,
ein öffentliches JavaScript-Asset, in dem die URL für das Backend drin stand.
Also in dem JavaScript-Asset erkennst du, ah, alles klar, hier,
da ist die Backend-API, du musst sie erstmal finden.
Da konntest du dann dazu führen, dass du eine, wenn du einen nicht authentifizierten
Get-Request gemacht hast, kam die Debug-Error-Page.
Also die Web-App lief im Debug-Modus. Was man auch nicht tun soll,
aber auch ein sehr klassischer Fehler,
weil in dem Debug-Modus gibt die Web-App bei einem Fehler, in diesem Fall,
du verstößt ja dagegen, sagst, hier ist ein unauthenticated Get-Request.
Und dann kriegst du aber die Debug-Error-Page, die einfach den kompletten State
und alles droppt, in dem die App sich gerade befindet, damit die Programmiererin
herausfinden kann, wo er halt gelegen.
Und das hat die Web-App, die Debug-Page hat alle Environment-Variablen mit ausgegeben,
weil an jeder davon kann es ja liegen.
Und zu den Environment-Variablen gehörte Username Admin und Passwort Admin at 123.
Oh Gott, nein.
Du hättest jetzt noch nicht mal, du hättest jetzt noch nicht mal Hätten.
Sie nicht Bonobo.
2342 Ja, das hätte man natürlich erkannt, okay.
Das war wirklich Anfänger.
Du hättest tatsächlich in der Wikipedia-Liste der am häufigsten verwendeten
Passwörter, das ist 19, ja, du hättest dir den ganzen Ärger gar nicht machen
müssen, René, also René Rehme.
So, dann konnte er natürlich, jetzt gehst du einfach hin und sagst,
alles klar, jetzt bin ich Admin, kannst dich an das Admin-Panel anmelden,
eine ganz normale Standard-Jungo-App Admin Panel.
Dann hat das Ding aber auch gelockt,
die OAuth-Tokens von den Authentifizierungen.
Also wenn jemand da hingeht und sagt, hallo, ich bin so und so at,
nicht McKinsey, sondern andere Firma.
Die zwischenzeitlich ausgegebenen Passierscheine.
Genau. Und mit denen konntest du dich wiederum dann, weil die von einem Entra-ID kamen,
mit denen konntest du dich dann wiederum an dem Microsoft Graph anmelden und
die anderen das Entra-ID querien, in dem Fall 3,2 Millionen User-Accounts. Ein bisschen mehr.
Okay.
Ein bisschen mehr als bei McKinsey.
Und also diese ganzen, also alle Chat-Logs und alle Dateien und auch die Pre-Promts,
das liegt halt in dieser Web-App drin. Wo soll es auch sonst liegen?
Also wirklich sehr parallel. Diesmal halt nur von einem Menschen gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie lange René gebraucht hat.
Üblicherweise braucht der nicht lange. Er hat dann noch mit Nina,
also im gleichen Team, dann diesen Kram gemacht, an dem Entra-ID rumgetrommelt,
um da die User-Accounts rauszuholen.
Und dann haben Matthias, also Kantorkel und ich noch einen kleinen Blogpost
dazu geschrieben und vor allem die Responsible Disclosure gemacht.
Also Bescheid gesagt.
Wir haben dann doch Bescheid gesagt, ja. Also ich kannte jemanden bei der Firma
und hab dann gesagt so, hast du mal Zeit?
Und dann, ja, morgen hab ich Zeit, da hab ich angerufen und dann wurde ich weggedrückt
und dann hab ich so gesagt, ey, hast du mal Zeit?
Wir müssen über diesen McKinsey-Chatbot reden. Im weitesten Sinne.
Und dann war das dann relativ schnell gefixt.
So, was das andere Thema hier ist, ähm,
Also wir haben, genau, erstmal, warum passiert das? Na klar,
da werden hastig irgendwelche Web-Apps gestrickt, damit man KI hat.
Und die Aufmerksamkeit, was man dann absichert, die ist natürlich bei der KI.
Und nicht, wir machen irgendwie eine scheiß Web-App, wir haben ja schon 100.000
Web-Apps gemacht, die coden wir einfach schnell runter.
Aber es ist eben wirklich nicht, also jetzt komme ich wieder auf den Fall von McKinsey,
wenn die App erstmal oder wenn die API erstmal genug Verzweigungen hat,
dann kommst du relativ schnell an den Punkt….
Dass du nicht mehr die ganze Zeit kontrollierst, ob du an dem Request,
der jetzt gerade kommt, ob alle Vorbedingungen auch wirklich erfüllt sind.
Also, ist der Nutzer authentifiziert? Ist der Nutzer autorisiert?
Ergibt sich das aus dem Kontext? Hat der mir alle Informationen gegeben,
die ich erzwingen muss, damit er das jetzt überhaupt darf? und so.
Diese Fehler passieren wirklich am laufenden Band und deswegen ist,
sag ich mal, ein Browser mit einer Burp Suite auch so ein Gift that keeps on giving.
Also im Prinzip ein Tool, was dafür gedacht ist, sehr gezielt in den Traffic
zu schauen, in die APN-Punkte, in das, was da geschickt wird.
Dann kannst du so, weiß nicht, wenn irgendwas Base64 ist, kannst du direkt sagen,
in die, encode das mal und vor allem kannst du Requests wiederholt schicken
oder da so ein bisschen durchproben.
Ja, ein Tool, was genau solche, es gibt eine API, die ich nicht kenne,
ich klimper da jetzt mal durch und ich versuch mal dieses und jenes,
ich automatisiere das durch, iteriere das mal und ach, zack, SQL Injection.
Also, dass eine KI das hinbekommt, ist erstmal nicht extrem überraschend,
weil es sehr alte, klassische 90er-Jahre-Schwachstellen sind,
aber in einem, eben in einer komplett neuen Web-App.
Also will man jetzt auch nicht schlecht reden und zwei Stunden ist auf jeden
Fall auch eine sehr stabile Zeit.
Im Sinne von gut. Schnell.
Das ist schon relativ schnell, ja. Aber wenn man nach dieser Sache gezielt sucht,
dann braucht man vielleicht auch nicht viel länger mit einer ganz guten Toolchain
und ein bisschen Erfahrung.
Aber trotzdem ist es natürlich spannend, dass das Ding das getan hat.
Oder dass das Ding das geschafft hat.
Der nächste Punkt war natürlich, die AI, also das Modell oder die Modellee dahinter
hat Zugriff auf alle Daten.
Auch das ist,
jetzt eigentlich so ein Security-Architecture-Paradigmen-Wechsel,
der da eigentlich gerade stattfindet.
Früher würdest du sagen, hier gibt es die Web-App.
Die Web-App prüft die Autorisierung der Nutzerin und führt dann die Aktion durch.
Nehmen wir ein einfaches, ich nehme jetzt WordPress mal als Beispiel,
weil ja Logbuch Netzpolitik auch auf WordPress gehostet ist.
Das WordPress selber hat auch nur eine Datenbank User Credential.
Das heißt, das WordPress selber kann jederzeit alles löschen.
Das heißt, die Prüfung von Authentisierung und Autorisierung findet in der PHP-Logik
von dem WordPress statt.
Und wenn man da jetzt als, was weiß ich, als Visitor ist oder als User oder
als Admin oder die unterschiedlichen Rollen, das macht alles das WordPress.
Und wenn irgendetwas da falsch ist und du irgendwo in dem WordPress Frontend
beispielsweise einen Fehler hast und eine SQL-Ejection ermöglichst,
dann wird das sofort mit dem höchst privilegierten User üblicherweise in dem
WordPress-Kontext mindestens.
Also du hast Zugriff auf das komplette WordPress.
Oder wenn du halt das schlechte, das falsche Tutorial auf Stack Overflow gelesen
hast, eben mit Root gemacht.
Und wenn der User in der Datenbank wiederum nicht ordentlich beschnitten ist,
dann kann der potenziell auch Code exekuten.
Also auch hier hast du im Prinzip das WordPress hat zu viele Rechte je nachdem
in welchem Kontext du dich in dem WordPress befindest und wenn das seine Authentisierung
und Autorisierung nicht ordentlich macht dann hat es eben zu viel Zugriff diesen,
Setup oder dieser Grundgedanke wird jetzt auch bei den KIs wiederholt dass man
der KI nämlich sagt naja okay natürlich kriegst du alle Daten.
Wäre ja auch viel zu anstrengend, die nicht zu geben. Aber pass mal bitte auf,
hier sind Daten, da schreiben wir dir jetzt eine Regel, das darfst du den Leuten nicht sagen.
Und dann versucht man in der KI in irgendeiner Weise das Rollenkonzept umzusetzen
und hofft, dass sie sich dran hält.
Wo man sich nicht so richtig drauf verlassen kann.
Das geht natürlich regelmäßig schief, weil die Grundanforderung dafür eigentlich
ist, dass du die Daten die die KI da so zugreift, vernünftig labelst.
Und dann könnte, dann wäre es zumindest theoretisch möglich,
dass die KI sagt, ja okay, das darf der, das ist eine Information,
die ist für diesen Nutzer, der jetzt da gerade zugreift, nicht geeignet. Ja?
Aber jetzt stell dir mal vor, du lässt so ein Ding, und das macht ja zum Beispiel
Microsoft Copilot, wir hatten das hier über, vor, weiß nicht,
wahrscheinlich ein paar Monaten mal besprochen.
Wenn du jetzt so ein Microsoft Copilot anmachst, dann nehmen die ihr LLM und
lassen das einmal den Sharepoint lesen.
Und wenn du dann sagst, ich brauche mal Dateien, in denen dieses oder jenes
drinsteht oder so, dann sagt er dir, hier sind die Dateien.
Du kannst aber auch einfach sagen, hör mal, wie waren denn einfach die Zahlen im letzten Quartal?
Und dann kriegst du potenziell eben auch eine Antwort, wenn sich nicht vorher
die Mühe gemacht wurde, diese Daten zu labeln.
Jetzt hast du aber natürlich insbesondere in Dateien hast du ja potenziell,
wenn jetzt ein Word-Dokument ist, 20 Seiten, dann ist da potenziell,
das ganze Dokument ist relativ irrelevant und ein kleines Faktum da drin ist ein Problem.
Oder willst du geheim halten? Dein LLM weiß das aber.
Und wenn du jetzt die Daten nicht so gegeben hast, dass das LLM das nicht,
dass es weiß, dass es das gibt und aber außerdem immer auch präsent hat,
das darf ich jemand anders nicht sagen.
Und ich kann nicht sagen, Ich kann nicht sagen, dass ich da bisher schon eine
architektonisch überzeugende Lösung gefunden habe, wo ich sage,
das ist langfristig tragfähig.
So.
Und ich diskutiere über solche Architekturen öfter mal mit Leuten,
wo auch jemand sagte, ich glaube das habe ich dir vielleicht sogar schon mal
erzählt, der sagte ja auch so, wir machen jetzt hier KI und Pipapo und alle
Daten Lake und alles Modelle davor und so.
Und ich hab gesagt, ey, Junge, du hast deine Karriere da mitverbracht,
dieses Unternehmen zu segregieren, Nutzerrechte und alles zu machen.
Firewalls, hier, da und so. Und jetzt geht ihr hin und kippt alles auf einen
Haufen und haut eine nicht-deterministische KI davor.
Klingt erstmal.
Ungewöhnlich. Ungewöhnliche Situation.
Und die Antwort war, Ja, ist richtig, aber das alte Konzept,
alles zu segregieren und authentifizieren und so rollenbasiert und so weiter,
hat ja auch nicht funktioniert.
Insofern, jetzt hat man wenigstens eine zentrale Stelle, an der man Authentisierung,
Autorisierung prüfen und auch zentral nachschärfen kann und an der man an einer
Stelle kontrollieren kann.
Du hast einen architektonischen Vorteil, dass sich deine Kontrollen nicht dezentral
über irgendwelche Requests in einem Netzwerk bewegen, aber die Komplexität von Zugriffsrechten,
Zugriffen und Rollen.
Wird unglaublich schnell so kompliziert, dass du da am laufenden Band Probleme hast.
Und das Beispiel, was wir hier haben, ist ja nur eine Web-App.
Da hast du ja wenigstens noch einen endlichen, also eine endliche Anzahl von
Regeln, die du prüfst in einer gegebenen Situation.
Und da kriegst du schon nicht hin, wo es ein formal endlicher,
also zumindest theoretisch endliche Menge an Regeln ist, die in unterschiedlichen
Kontexten zum Tragen kommen.
Also die gesamte Web-App ist ja immer noch deterministisch.
So, jetzt hast du aber eine KI und du weißt ja gar nicht, in was für Kontexte
und Zustände Leute die bringen,
wo du jetzt sagst, okay, ein Nutzer vom Stande der normalen Mitarbeiterinnen
darf niemals die Quartalszahlen sehen.
Und du hast aber relativ schnell eine, dass du sagst, wenn das Haus brennt,
muss der Nutzer hier raus oder so.
Dass du sehr schnell in Situationen kommst, wo du den Kontext nicht mehr vollständig überblicken kannst.
Und es ist wirklich eine große Herausforderung, die ich glaube,
die wirklich, weil ja erkennbar nun die Zeiten vorbei sind,
dass wir Programme schreiben und das ist gerade alles vorbei,
das sind hier die Beispiele.
Dass die Leute bei McKinsey hingehen und sagen, was kostet das hier,
zack, alles kippt drauf, zack, bumm, machst eine Django-App davor oder was und dann gib ihm.
Das findet gerade überall auf der Welt statt. Und tatsächlich glaube ich,
dass jetzt wirklich IT-Sicherheit und Security.
Safety, Qualitätskontrolle, all das, das muss jetzt noch sich entwickeln,
was die brauchbaren Controls, in diesen Situationen sind.
Ich glaube, dass die Lösung sein wird,
dass du wiederum zwischen das, was die KI macht und die Daten im Prinzip wieder
irgendwelche Controls machst,
APIs, auf denen du monitorst und guckst, okay, was haben wir am einen Ende,
was macht die gerade, Darf die das überhaupt? Ergibt sich das gerade aus dem Kontext?
Aber eine belastbare Implementierung, die universell funktionieren kann,
wie man das immer noch gerade zumindest theoretisch hinkriegt mit deterministischen
Systemen, wo es ja auch schon nicht klappt.
Und das sehe ich jetzt für nicht-deterministische AIs umso weniger.
Also ich glaube, die Lösung wird sein, A, B.
Dem Ding APIs zu geben, auf denen man irgendwie kontrolliert Regeln auf den
Informationsfluss wieder setzen kann.
Und andererseits KIs zu nehmen, die nicht zu klug sind für ihre Aufgabe.
Das war ja hier dieses Beispiel mit dem, was wir hier vor einiger Zeit auch
besprochen hatten, dieses Anthropic-Experiment, wo die Automaten betrieben hat.
Und wo der dann auf einmal einen Controller bekommen hat und dann haben die
sich nachts über transzendentale Philosophie unterhalten. Super.
Was machst du am Watercooler?
Das ist wie im richtigen Leben, Linus.
Aber das sind auch genau die gefährlichen Leute.
Ja. man muss auch sehen, was dieses McKinsey-Beispiel betrifft, was ich jetzt.
Ich lege Wert auf die Festlegung, dass die beiden Beispiele sehr ähnlich sind.
Ja, ja, aber jetzt, also ja, okay, gut, wie auch immer, also unabhängig davon, wer es ist,
also auf der einen Seite kann man feststellen, es gibt jetzt einen großen Run
auf Adoption dieser Systeme, weil sie natürlich einen offensichtlichen Nutzen haben.
Und was Security betrifft, haben wir immer dieses Problem,
Security ist irgendwie anstrengend, weil es macht die Sachen dann unkomfortabel
im Zugriff und alle wollen immer komfortabel im Zugriff haben und das hat immer
dazu geführt, dass Passwörter einfach waren oder eben umgangen wurden oder man
dachte, das passt schon irgendwie.
Das ist immer dieses Race zwischen Convenience und Security.
Und jetzt haben wir halt diesen Run auf diese AI-Systeme, die so verheißungsvoll
sind und das ist ja so nützlich und in gewisser Hinsicht sind wir in dieser
ganzen Adoptionsphase, die jetzt unvermeidbar ist, im Mittelalter angekommen.
Und man haut jetzt erstmal alles zusammen und ach guck mal, läuft schon, super.
Und die offensichtlich erforderlichen Mitigationen dieser Security-Probleme,
die halt also ein sehr viel mehr so ein Schichtenmodell erfordert,
wo sich immer wieder KI mit so einem deterministischen System abwechseln muss,
das sind Architekturen, die müssen sich jetzt erst herausbilden.
Und da brauchst du auch noch Erfahrungen, da brauchst du auch noch neue Software,
neue Erkenntnisse und vor allem auch Einsichten bei diesem Unternehmen.
Die Unternehmen sollten aber auch vor allem bedenken, das gilt ja jetzt nicht
nur für so große Unternehmen, sondern auch für kleinere Unternehmen,
die das vielleicht jetzt genauso als Chance sehen, was es ja auch sein kann.
Dass umso mehr man eben auf diesen Haufen kippt und umso mehr man da reinwirft.
Bisher sind so Datenbanken verloren gegangen, die Kunden waren weg oder die
Auftragsliste oder sowas und das ist alles schon ganz schön schlimm.
Aber was ja McKinsey und all diese Unternehmen, die jetzt ihr ganzes Firmenwissen
da reinkippen, auch noch mit rausgeben, ist, dass sie auch noch ihren kompletten Modus operandi,
auch ihre Einstellung und ihre Ziele und ihre Methoden und sogar auch noch ihre
ganzen geheimen Arten und Weisen, wie sie vorgehen,
ihre ganzen Konspirationen auch noch gleich dem Netz überantworten und auslesbar machen.
Also Maschinenlesbarkeit bekommt auf einmal nochmal eine ganz andere Dimension,
weil die Maschinen es nicht nur lesen können, sondern dass diese Maschinen auch
noch sehr viel mehr aus diesen Informationen herauslesen können,
als es früher war und das macht die Sache natürlich noch dringender,
dass man hier fünfmal darüber nachdenkt, wie man seine Security-Architektur gestaltet.
Man muss gerade kurz zwei Dinge noch eben trennen.
Und diese Hacks, das ist ja das, also das ist das, sag ich mal,
auf der Meta-Ebene Interessante daran, die haben überhaupt nichts mit der AI zu tun.
Das ist das Erste. Das heißt, wir bauen was Neues und machen immer noch die
Fehler aus den Neuen zu haben.
Also nicht mit deren AI, aber schon mit den Tools, die jetzt in der Lage sind,
schneller herauszufinden.
Ja, also das finde ich, muss ich wirklich sagen, das finde ich noch nicht so,
noch nicht ganz so beeindruckend.
Das sind wirklich Dinge, die sind...
Du findest das nicht so beeindruckend, aber ich glaube, das ist schon ganz schön beeindruckend.
Ja, das mag sein, dass es für jemanden, der es nicht selber kann,
ist es immer beeindruckend.
Aber diese... Würdest du... unter der Annahme, dass die KI irgendwann mal ein
Buch über IT-Security gelesen hat, in ihrer mehrmonatigen Trainingsphase, wo irgendwie so ein,
paar Boote in dieser Meerstraße von Honduras oder wo,
verbrannt wurden.
Hommus.
Ja. Ich wollte ja nur mal hier wieder meine geografische, mit meiner geografischen
Unkenntnis kokettieren.
Unter der Annahme, dass sie jemals gelesen hat, was häufige Fehler sind,
finde ich es jetzt nicht überraschend, dass sie, wenn sie mit einer API,
konfrontiert ist und vor allem die vollständige API-Dokumentation kriegt,
dass sie die systematisch durchklimpert.
Es ist auch nicht überraschend, dass sie SQL-Injections versucht,
Schön, ich würde jetzt vermuten, beeindruckend ist sicherlich,
dass sie das wahrscheinlich auch nur bei den Endpunkten gemacht hat,
wo die Vermutung nahe liegt, dass das überhaupt etwas ist, was in Richtung einer Datenbank geht.
Das wäre so die erste Sache und an der kurzen Zeit sieht man schon,
dass sie es im Zweifelsfall auch gemacht hat.
Ähm aber das Niveau also,
weißt du, es ist noch nicht das Level von hier, das Ding hat als Großmeister.
Im Go auf einmal Züge gemacht, die keiner kannte und die völlig irrsinnig erschienen,
aber dann am Ende gewonnen weil, das Level ist es noch nicht.
Aber ich glaub, so weit sind wir da auch nicht von entfernt also das kommt,
glaub ich noch alles in dieser Dekade.
Der andere Aspekt, das war das zweite, was du gerade sagtest,
jetzt kippen die alle ihre Daten da rein,
es würde mich wundern, wenn diese KI, die da am, wo diese Web-App am Ende hingepipt
hat, jetzt irgendwie, was weiß ich, beim McKinsey-KI war.
Das war wahrscheinlich, also war doch dann wahrscheinlich entweder irgendwas
von Google Gemini, von OpenAI oder von Anthropic, würde ich jetzt mal...
Gehostet das System meinst du?
Ja, also wäre jetzt meine Erwartung.
Und dann wird ja dieser Aspekt, den du gerade nanntest mit dem,
wir müssen jetzt noch die Architekturen dafür finden, alles richtig,
Während wir an den gelösten Problemen von vor 20, 30 Jahren scheitern.
Das würde ich da nur noch kurz hinzufügen.
Es bleibt unterhaltsam auf jeden Fall.
Achso, hier muss ich noch sagen, wir haben ja unter unserem Blogpost noch geschrieben,
wer Lust hat, in einem solchen Team zu arbeiten, kann ja gerne mal sich bei uns melden.
Ich dachte, man wird da jetzt auch von der KI dann abgelöst demnächst.
Also kann ich mich jetzt nicht zu äußern, die hören ja vielleicht zu.
Also,
glaube ich, ist jetzt kein Geheimnis, dass dieser KI, diese KI-Entwicklung natürlich
im Bereich der IT und auch der IT-Security.
Klar, dieses Beispiel, das Ding macht da in zwei Stunden so eine Web-App auf.
Als Vergleich würde ich schon denken, dass man an sowas am Ende dann doch eine
Woche Pentester gehabt hätte.
Und das ist natürlich schon die Dimensionen, die zeitlichen Dimensionen sind
ja hier das entscheidende.
Also in zwei Stunden macht ein Mensch das mit hoher Qualifikation und sehr viel Glück.
Und ich denke, eine realistische Zeit für das wäre wahrscheinlich irgendwo zwischen
mit hoher Qualifikation und Glück einen Tag dieses Ergebnis zu liefern.
Nach einer Woche oder fünf Tagen würde ich sowas erwarten, dass solche Schwachstellen
gefunden werden von einer qualifizierten Person.
Aber dann kann man sich natürlich auch noch vorstellen, wie so eine KI halt
auch noch den Bericht schreibt innerhalb dieser zwei Stunden in drei Sekunden
oder so. Oder vielleicht 40.
Das heißt, da ist natürlich im Security-Bereich gerade durchaus...
Zeiten des Umbruchs.
Gleichermaßen, wenn du am Ende
noch nicht mal dazu kommst, dich mit den schönen neuen KI, Architektur,
rechte Modellen, Schwachstellen auseinanderzusetzen, weil du schon am Anfang
über Admin 1.123 stolperst und über SQL Injections und schlecht,
durchdachte API-Authentifizierung,
dann bleibt auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen Zeit.
So, was kann man denn noch mit KI Schönes machen?
Muss mal gucken, was man mit KI machen kann. Ich hatte hier schon die Shownotes zu, weil ich sonst...
Überwachen kann man damit, super.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, können wir machen, kein Problem. Zum Beispiel in Berlin.
Ja, das ist doch naheliegend, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Berlin ist ja in den Händen der,
CDU.
Und SPD.
Ach ja, die sind ja immer noch dabei.
Ja, also wir kriegen jetzt die Novelle des Berliner Polizeigesetzes wurde verabschiedet.
Wir haben jetzt Verhaltensscanner, Gesichtserkennung, Datenanalyse,
so pallant hier alles auf einen Haufen, wie bei McKinsey.
Staatsruhjahre machen sie auch.
Und haben jetzt auch ausgeschrieben, sie wollen eine Software für KI-Videoschutz.
Haben sie ausgeschrieben.
Wer soll da geschützt werden?
Der öffentliche Raum.
Ah.
Das ist dann so wie in Hamburg gibt es das ja schon länger und es gibt jetzt wenn ich das richtig,
in Erinnerung habe, schon noch in diesem Jahr werden dann,
erste KI unterstützte Videosysteme an den,
ich glaube am Alex oder Cottbusser Tor oder sowas an den Hotspots der Kriminalität,
Ja, Cottbusser Tor, ganz schlimm.
Wobei da würde ich sagen, also bei den meisten Leuten am Kotti,
wenn ich mich bedroht fühlen würde, würde ich einfach weggehen.
Schaffen die nicht, mich anzuholen.
Na, kommt drauf an.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall hochproblematisch.
Das sprießt jetzt überall aus dem Boden. Frankfurt hat bei mobiler Gesichtserkennung
Razzia im Bahnhofsviertel mit 200 Beamten,
haben sie eine Foto-App zur Personenidentifikation in Echtzeit verwendet.
414 Menschen mit einer Gesichts-App irgendwie untersucht.
Und,
dann Auf was? Also die haben glaube ich nach einer Person gesucht.
Also die haben nach einem Menschen gesucht und die haben aber dann auch die
Personen, die da waren, einfach gesagt, wer sie sind, quasi um sich nicht immer
einen Ausweis zeigen zu lassen.
Gesichtserkennung, zack, bumm. Hier, wie hieß die,
Wie hieß die Raff-Terroristin?
Daniela Klette.
Ja, genau. Quasi dieses, wer ist diese Person? Ah ja, okay, zack, bumm.
Und, ähm, also das, so ich meine, Gesichtserkennung ist das eine Ding, ne?
Und das ist ja heute schon, sag ich mal, offener ist nur noch eine Frage des,
wie viel Ressourcen und Geld nimmst du in die Hand, wenn du beispielsweise jetzt
einen öffentlichen Raum überwachst, einfach jedes Gesicht da drin automatisch zu erkennen, ne?
Das ist jetzt keine Herausforderung.
Und was sie auch haben, ist dann Verhaltensüberwachung. Da verhält sich aber jemand komisch.
Der braucht ja ein bisschen länger, um sein Fahrrad aufzuschließen oder sonst was.
Und in Kombinationen bist du dann eben bei den Sachen, die eigentlich immer
so im öffentlich-rechtlichen Nachtprogramm sind. In China, schaut ihr das an,
die komplette verdattete Überwachung.
Und da wird jetzt gerade das solide polizeigesetzliche Fundament für gelegt.
Also ich meine, die ganzen Überwachungsfantasien waren ja schon immer da.
Schon in den 80er Jahren ging das ja los nach dieser Terrorzeit der 70er mit
Rasterfahndung und dieser Traum von alles jederzeit sehen,
um eine Sicherheit herzustellen, die ausschließlich auf dieser Idee einer Kontrolle basiert.
Das gab es immer und es ist eigentlich nur daran gescheitert,
dass das, was man machen wollte mit der Technik, am Ende zu teuer war.
Aber jetzt, wo die Technologie immer billiger wird und sich in gewisser Hinsicht
ja auch die Möglichkeiten immer weiter ergeben werden.
Also Kameras waren früher teuer, super teuer.
Also von digitalen Kameras mal ganz abgesehen.
Und heutzutage ist eine Kamera halt wirklich nur noch ein Pfennigbetrag in der
elektronischen Produktion.
Datenmengen speichern war teuer, heute kriegst du irgendwie Terabytes auf dem
Daumennagel unter und so weiter und mit diesen gesunkenen Kosten steigt natürlich
auch automatisch dieser Durst nach,
jetzt machen wir alles, was wir schon immer machen wollen.
Du hast den einen Aspekt vergessen,
noch zu nennen, du hast, klar, dann hast du massenhaft Video,
dann musst du das speichern können.
Das, was jetzt dir gelingt, ist, massenhaft Video auch analysieren zu können.
Das war so die letzte, also Video aufzeichnen konntest du, du hattest nur dann halt mehr Heu.
Also in den 80ern noch nicht, aber dann später war das auch und jetzt ist eben
auch noch diese ganze Analyse und daraus auch noch einen Sinn machen.
Auch das wird jetzt machbar und ist halt in gewisser Hinsicht günstig.
Wir hatten auch hier in der Sendung ja über die Ring-Geschichte da mit dem wir
haben mit dieser Überwachungsfirma ein wunderschönes Feature,
mit dem man deinen Hund wiederfinden kann.
So, Alter, what the fuck, ey, also den Hund, dafür habt ihr das Geld ausgegeben.
So, so, das ist immer voll lieb, dass ihr euch für meinen Hund interessiert.
So, ist außerdem ein Leguan und der ist tot.
Echt, du hast einen toten Leguan als Haustier?
Nein, ich habe keinen Leguan. Leguan gehört nicht nach Deutschland.
Leguan ist kein Teil von Deutschland.
Die Insel heißt anders. Das verwechselst du.
Leguan, wirklich. Leguan ist kein Teil von Deutschland.
Ja. Ist nicht gut. Videoüberwachung. Deswegen hat der CCC auch gesagt, ist doof.
Ja, Kantorkel gerade schon erwähnt.
Ein teures, aber gefährliches Sicherheitstheater. Und ja, also nochmal,
also wie viel Kriminalität.
Erwartest du.
Also wirklich so die Ökonomie davon, ne? Wir können jedes Gesicht erkennen mit der Kamera.
Wir erkennen verdächtiges Verhalten.
Okay, haben wir eventuell ein bisschen überinvestiert, weil trotzdem findet
ihr die ganze Zeit Kriminalität unter diesen Kameras oder vielleicht nicht unter diesen Kameras statt?
Kann das sein, dass die Leute einfach irgendwo hingehen, wo die Kamera nicht
ist? War das vielleicht so?
Dann müssen wir da auch eine Kamera hinstellen oder was? Dann wird das irgendwie
ein bisschen teurer. Und dann am Ende sind die Kriminellen da, wo keine Kamera ist.
Wie viele Kameras müssen wir kaufen, dass die nirgendwo mehr hinkönnen?
Und was bedeutet das dann für unseren öffentlichen Raum? Dann können wir uns
nicht mehr unüberwacht von diesen Systemen, die in der Lage sind,
anormales Verhalten festzustellen und unsere Gesichter zu erkennen. Ja, geil.
Also, ich glaube, ich hatte das hier vor einiger Zeit auch schon mal in der Sendung gesagt.
Dann wird der öffentliche Raum, durch den wir uns gerade noch frei bewegen können.
Wir können da einfach lang gehen. Das kriegt keiner mit. Das erfasst auch keiner zentral. Im Moment.
Aber das wird dann wie im Internet. Egal wo du lang gehst, egal wo du hast,
Datenspuren hinterlassen, zack, bumm, ach, du bist da lang gehst.
Ja, 85 Hikvision-KI-Kameras.
Ja.
Die haben auch dein Gesicht erkannt. Die haben auch gemerkt,
dass du da an der einen Straßenecke, Tim, da weiß ich gar nicht,
ob du da jetzt, also, so wie du da in dem Bus stand, hast du da hingepinkelt, das kostet doch 10 Euro.
20, glaube ich, eigentlich sogar jetzt, mit dem neuen Polizeigesetz.
Ja, man wird dann mit allem möglichen in Verbindung gebracht.
Also das schafft einfach eine, also hättest du, sagen wir mal,
muss ich jetzt gar nicht mal so groß aufziehen, reicht jetzt mal nur so ein Stadtteil.
Sagen wir mal, man hat so ein Problemstadtteil.
Kreuzberg ist ja immer gerne in Diskussionen.
Nehmen wir Grunewald.
Ja, oder Grunewald, genau. Da fahren die aber nur mit dem Auto lang, das ist ja einfach.
Stell mal einen Kennzeichenscanner hin, was dann los ist.
Ja, aber das ist ja einfach. Also die Konservativen sehen ja die Bösen immer
in Kreuzberg und in jede Straße muss jetzt so eine KI-Kamera rein und dann haben wir diese ganzen Daten.
Und ich will auch nicht mal ausschließen, dass man damit auch irgendwelches Kriminelles macht.
Geschehen, erfassen könnte. Ist durchaus wahrscheinlich.
Vor allem schafft man aber einen Datensatz, auf dem potenziell jede denkbare Analyse möglich ist.
Und das betrifft natürlich die Privatsphäre quasi aller Leute in diesem Bereich.
Es schafft vor allem auch Erpressungspotenzial.
Es sind Daten mit einem sehr hohen Wert und wir wissen, alles was einen sehr
hohen Wert hat, das wird dann auch irgendwann verkauft werden,
wird dann anderen Leuten zugespielt werden.
Das sind ja sozusagen Beobachtungssehens. Ich meine, kurzer Blick hier auf den
Iran-Krieg, der erste Schlag auf den Ayatollah, der von Israel durchgeführt wurde.
Es kam ja im Nachhinein raus, dass Israel seit...
Jahren alle Verkehrskameras in Teheran abgeschnorchelt hatten.
Die haben sozusagen einen Livestream gehabt von dieser Hauptstadt,
also nicht nur einen Livestream, sondern alle Livestreams und die haben darüber
die ganzen Wege der Mitarbeiter dieser Ministerien und Zuträger und Sicherheitspersonal
darüber analysiert und haben darüber sozusagen ein klares Bild gehabt, wer ist wann,
wo, welche Routinen herrschen, Was ist sozusagen hier das Sicherheitsregime?
Und unter anderem mit diesen Informationen, sicherlich nicht nur mit diesen
Informationen, unter anderem mit diesen Informationen, dann ein relativ klares
Bild gehabt, wer ist wann wo und wo können wir zu welchem Zeitpunkt zuschlagen.
Das ist so die Dimension, die allein die Verkehrskameras schon.
Diese News sollten wir mehr verbreiten, wenn dann demnächst solche Kameras in
Berlin aufgestellt werden.
Wenn wir sagen, Israel, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Dass es so ist. Ich wollte das jetzt nicht auf Israel bringen, sondern generell.
Mir ist ja völlig egal, wer die Kamera absägt. Hauptsache die ist wieder weg.
Ja aber es ist also diese Gesamtüberwachung es gab ja schon vor,
wie lange ist das schon wieder her da war dann irgendwie ich glaube der Michael
Kreil hatte das gemacht der hatte quasi gesagt okay wenn man die Menge an Daten
die die Stasi gesammelt hat nimmt,
und macht die in Aktenordner und dann macht man daraus Regalmeter und dann hat
er quasi eine Fläche aus Regalmetern gemalt und dann hat er die Menge an Daten, die die NSA hatte,
einfach mal visualisiert und das war natürlich ein Vielfaches und.
Die Stasi ist an ihre Kapazitätsgrenzen geraten, daraus noch Erkenntnis zu ziehen.
Die mussten dann ja quasi so Informationspyramiden bauen.
Jeder überwacht da, der IM überwacht, irgendjemand schreibt einen Bericht und
dann der schreibt wieder da einen Bericht und dann hast du irgendwann,
versuchst du es irgendwie noch für einen Menschen oder ein, was auch immer,
ein Blockwart oder was da die
Struktur war, irgendwie hochzufiltern und zu aggregieren die Information.
Aber am Ende war das Bottleneck noch so, am Ende muss das noch in das Gehirn
von ein paar Menschen passen.
Und auch das bist du dann los, wenn du massenhafte Datenanalysen in Echtzeit machen kannst.
Und das ist es ist wirklich als Ausmaß,
sowas von,
nicht mehr vorstellbar, wie viel krass invasiver und überwachender das ist.
Nimm mir den Schlaf. Kommen wir zum nächsten Thema.
Ja, also es ist so ein totales ist auch so ein Zauberlehrlingsding. Also man, ich kann...
Der Friedrich Merz sieht jetzt nicht aus wie ein Zauberlehrling.
Naja, also...
Selbst wenn ich es jetzt mal ganz gutmütig, positiv annehmen würde, was ihre Ziele sind.
Ah ja, sie wollen die Kriminalität reduzieren, sie wollen irgendwie die gefühlte
oder auch die reale Sicherheit an öffentlichen Plätzen herstellen.
Und es gibt ja auch Problemorte und es gibt auch Problemsituationen.
Kann man alles irgendwie einsehen.
Ich würde ihnen sogar fast mal unterstellen, dass sie das selber so sehen.
Dass sie überhaupt gar nicht darüber nachdenken, was das Missbrauchspotenzial
davon ist, sondern dass das für sie einfach zweitrangig ist manche vielleicht
nicht, aber einige sehen es sicherlich,
in so einer gutartigen Sache, also was habt ihr denn so wie diese Diskussion
um Wahlcomputer ja was denn, wir wollen das doch nur einfach machen und so weiter,
das kann doch nicht sein, dass man das nicht mit Computern machen kann,
ja naja okay, das seht ihr vielleicht so,
aber habt ihr mal wirklich darüber nachgedacht, was das bedeutet was das für
Konsequenzen haben kann Und das ist das Problematische daran.
Also ich glaube, es ist auch nicht klug, diese ganze politische Debatte immer
so mit der Unterstellung zu führen, dass die ja uns doof sind.
Ja, das vielleicht schon, aber dass sie nicht schaden wollen,
aber dass sie sich einfach über die potenziellen Auswirkungen der Installation
einer solchen Infrastruktur klar werden müssen und ich finde bei den anderen
Sachen, wo wir früher immer schon gewarnt haben,
hat sich das alles auch sehr wohl gezeigt, diese ganzen Probleme und das muss man auch oft.
Möchtest du sagen, told you so?
Naja, also,
es gibt genug Belege so was Privatschutz und Leakage von Daten und so weiter
betrifft und das wird jetzt hier auch nicht sehr viel anders sein aber die Auswirkungen
davon sind potenziell noch schlimmer.
Gehen wir gleich noch an Kotti. Letzte Mal jetzt, bevor da bald Videoüberwachung ist.
Schnell auch verdächtig am Kotti lang gehen.
Ein Döner, ganz verdächtig ein Döner essen.
Vielleicht noch kurz für die Vollständigkeit. In Thüringen läuft es gerade mit
einem KI-Polizeigesetz.
Verhaltensscanner, Gesichtssuchmaschine, Datenanalyse, Palantir-Style,
Kennzeichenscanner, Videodrohnen.
Niedersachsen hat auch ein KI-Polizeigesetz, BND,
du hast,
also natürlich wollen alle diese Strafverfolger und die Geheimdienste und die
Big Four Consultants, wie McKinsey,
alle Daten zentralisiert,
analysieren und diese Macht haben. Also das Bittere ist ja, die werden die sich
ja auch holen. Das ist ja auch wirklich nur so ein,
also,
das günstigste Ergebnis ist, dass wir durch den Widerstand dagegen uns noch
so viel Zeit verschaffen, dass wir vernünftigen Schutz dagegen noch entwickeln können.
Aber auch nicht so einfach, weil Meta, das ist ja auch, weißt du,
was machen wir bloß mit diesen ganzen Rechten?
Die Leute gehen in die Hände dieser Bauernfänger, die gehen da irgendwie bei
der AfD und den ganzen komischen rechtsgerichteten Irrsinnigen hin,
weil die das Vertrauen in die Politik verloren haben. Was machen wir denn?
Ja, lass uns am besten erstmal die oberste Datenschutzbeauftragte Irlands wird
jetzt Lobbyistin für Facebook und dann lass uns am besten die Ex-Meta-Lobbyistin,
die dann auf einmal ins EU-Parlament gekommen ist,
die nehmen wir am besten als Chefverhandlerin für den KI-Omnibus.
Also eine Ex-Meta-Lobbyistin sitzt jetzt im EU-Parlament und ist ausgerechnet für den KI-Omnibus.
Also für den KI-Teil des Omnibus.
Da. Also für KI und Datenschutz.
Das kann doch auch nicht sein. Also hatten wir wirklich niemand anders?
Ja, hatten wir wahrscheinlich nicht. Fällt dir noch jemand ein,
wenn man da hätte hinschicken können?
Thomas.
Ja, der war aber nicht bei Facebook.
Schlechtes Zivil.
Keine Ahnung, wovon er redet.
Es gibt,
In diesem ganzen Kontext, wir haben ja gerade über KI, Überwachung,
Auswertung und sowas gesprochen,
noch eine etwas unschöne Meta-Entwicklung.
Also natürlich, wir haben gesagt, Geheimdienste wollen das,
Überwachung will das und wir haben glaube ich in einer der letzten Sendungen
auch schon darüber gesprochen,
Militär will das, das Kriegsministerium der USA hat ja, auch darüber haben wir
gesprochen, sich mit Anthropic angelegt und jetzt irgendwie gesagt,
wir nehmen euch das Geld,
geben euch das Geld nicht mehr, dann einen Deal mit OpenAI gemacht.
Dann hat Trump gesagt, die Nutzung von Anthropic in Bundesbehörden wird jetzt untersagt.
Das heißt, sie versuchen Anthropic den Geldhahn zuzudrehen, um diese Entwicklungen
für sich gefügig zu machen.
Sowieso werden Kriege inzwischen mit Drohnen und automatisierten Tötungsmaschinen
geführt. Das heißt, die ganze Militärgeschichte.
Und wir haben gerade darüber gesprochen, dass wir im Prinzip beobachten,
dass die Sicherheitsarchitekturen für derartige Systeme zumindest,
also sie werden gerade exploriert das muss man jetzt mal noch finden,
und dann hat weitestgehend unbeachtet Donald Trump vor einigen Wochen eine neue
Cyber-Strategie veröffentlicht.
Und diese Strategie, die Donald Trump jetzt für, also für, wie bewegt man sich
im Bereich des Cyber, also Cyber ist ja Hacking, ne?
Sie haben gesagt, okay, wir gehen weg von Regulierung, wir gehen hin zu Dominanz und Deregulierung.
Also wir deregulieren die Anforderungen.
Das ist erstmal etwas, was ich gar nicht, also der Idee wäre ich gar nicht so abgeneigt,
weil in vielen Bereichen IT-Sicherheit tatsächlich so stark totreguliert ist,
dass es in die Sinnlosigkeit treibt.
Es wird viel zu viel Zeit verschwendet mit sinnlosen Anforderungen.
Aber das kombinieren sie mit, wir wollen den Bereich dominieren und wir priorisieren
den Angriff gegenüber der Verteidigung.
Also proaktive Angriffe, Abschreckung
und so weiter, statt in Resilienz zu investieren und zu setzen.
Also Abschreckung statt stabilen Scheiß bauen.
Genau, die Deregulierung, okay, also kann man drüber reden, das muss natürlich
nur die Zeit und Energie und Verpflichtung, die da frei wird,
die Ressourcen, die müssen ja auch irgendwo hin.
Dann natürlich ja mit KI, das machen wir jetzt hier Agentic AI wird dann für
uns die aktiven Cyber-Angriffe machen ähm und ja das ist äh,
Ich meine jetzt auch keine so gute Entwicklung, wenn jetzt die USA sagen,
wir haben uns überlegt, das mit dem Defense, das habt ihr jetzt ein paar Jahre
versucht, das funktioniert doch alles nicht. Wir kloppen einfach feste drauf.
Und dann denkt man sich, wie blöd sind eigentlich die USA, aber natürlich kriegen
BKA und Bundespolizei gerade auch neue Hackerbefugnisse oder so,
und die kriegen, das plant zumindest die Bundesregierung und sagt,
ja wir wollen natürlich aktive Abwehr von Hackerangriffen.
Wer das für eine gute Idee hält,
kann sich die schöne Sendung mit dem Hackback-Rakete nochmal anhören.
Also gegen Attacken, Systeme von Angreifern stören oder lahmlegen,
soll dann Bundespolizei und BKA erlaubt werden.
Und das wird auch nicht lange dauern, bis die sagen, das machen wir hier mit
dieser Codewall-KI oder was auch immer, die so schön das McKinsey-Problem fast gelöst hatte.
Und jetzt schwanken quasi nicht nur alle hin zu der Massenüberwachung und der
Automatisierung von Dingen mit wackelnden,
Sicherheitskonzepten und Zauberlehrlings Vibes, sondern sagen außerdem ja pass
auf, wir haben uns auch überlegt der Schwerpunkt ist jetzt eher wir greifen
die anderen an, als dass wir uns verteidigen ja,
Da würde ich auch sagen, wollen wir mal gucken, wie lange das dauert,
bis einer weint und ob nicht am Ende beide weinen.
Also diese amerikanische Regierung ist wirklich
völlig ohne irgendwelche
Guardrails unterwegs und diesen psychisch kranken Menschen da einfach freien
Lauf zu lassen und ihnen auch beliebige Loonies da in Führungspositionen in
den Ministerien bringen zu lassen,
das ist wahrscheinlich der größte Fehler in den USA je gemacht haben.
Aber das wird natürlich extreme Auswirkungen haben darauf,
wie auch andere Länder sich positionieren und das geht nicht gut.
Ja, genau. Es geht nicht gut.
Ich rede da ja nun wirklich mit dem Mund fusselig.
Ja, es gibt Angriffe. Ja, es gibt Angreifer.
Und ja, es gibt keine vollständige Sicherheit.
Genau deswegen muss man Resilienz aufbauen und nicht sagen, naja,
wenn wir eh verloren sind dann kloppen wir halt auf die anderen drauf also das
funktioniert halt nicht insbesondere,
wenn du dir dann sowas anhörst, wie du gerade erzählt hast dass dir eine dir
nicht wohlgesonnene Nation deine dir selbst dahingestellten Überwachungskameras hackt.
Ja, aber der neue 3er BMW ist super. Wird noch was in Deutschland.
So, dann haben wir noch einen Space, den gemeinnützigen Makerspace Toolbox Bodensee.
Die suchen relativ kurzfristig ein neues Zuhause.
Die müssen am 31.05.26 ausziehen und suchen mindestens 220 Quadratmeter im Bereich
Bodensee. Also der Bodensee-Kreis, Markdorf, Friedrichshafen, Tettnang.
Wir haben den Blogpost für euch verlinkt.
E-Mail an vorstand.toolbox-bodensee.de. Und warum würde man so einem Space ein Zuhause bieten?
Nun ja, das sind halt Orte, wo was passiert, wo Kreatives entsteht,
wo sich Communities treffen, Chaos treffen, Marktdorf, Funkamateure.
Freifunk-Bodensee, die Freifunk-WLAN-Infrastrukturen
bauen, Spieleentwicklung-Bodensee, IoT-Meetup.
Und die haben jetzt gerade 420 Quadratmeter, bauen Elektrotechnik,
Holz, Metallwerkstatt,
3D-Druck, Siebdruck, Fotolabor, also all diese Orte oder all diese Werkstätten und Tools,
die es ermöglichen, Dinge zu
tun, sich zu entfalten, als Communities zusammenzukommen, was zu machen.
Also damit man nicht immer nur hier mit Chat-GPT am Sexten ist,
sondern sich auch weiterentwickelt als Teenager.
Und ich denke, das sind wichtige, herausragende Orte von Kultur und Kreativität
und deswegen will man das haben.
Ja, und deswegen brauchen wir jetzt relativ kurzfristig dafür eine Fläche und
das ist eine Gelegenheit.
Das ist eine Chance, die sich so schnell nicht mehr bieten wird,
dass man jetzt die neue Heimat der Toolbox Bodensee werden kann,
am Bodensee, wo man eigentlich denkt, man hätte schon alles erreicht.
Ich glaube, wenn man da was zu vermieten hat, kann man nur sagen, das sind meistens...
Vom Vermieten war nicht die... Miete. Verschenken.
Verschenken?
Nein. Über eine angemessene Miete kann man...
Nicht angemessen, angemessene Miete ist so ein... Über eine vernünftige Miete kann man reden.
Ja, vor allem, wenn man was zu vermieten hat und man sucht so Mieter.
Ja, die das ordentlich halten. Die den Schrott dann erstmal reparieren,
indem man den da vermietet.
Ja, also, sag mal so, es gibt Mieter, die zahlen Miete, aber es gibt Mieter,
die zahlen Miete und bringen eine Kultur mit rein, die auch anderweitig ganz nützlich sein kann.
Das ist eine Aufwertung. Und da ist, also haben glaube ich die wenigsten bisher
bereut, die Leute an so einen Megaspace vermietet haben.
Nee, wüsste ich jetzt auch keinen.
Auf gar keinen Fall.
Ein Verschwörhaus in Ulm. Die haben ja dann irgendwann den Namen geklaut und
sich das, aber nee, also selbst das war...
Die haben den Namen geklaut, weil es so geil war, dass sie sagten,
das können wir nicht dulden, dass das euers ist, wir registrieren die Marke, das war unsers.
Naja, also wer was hat im Bereich Bodensee, soll sich mal melden bei den Leuten.
So, kommen wir zu den Terminen. Du hast schon einen erwähnt.
Ja, 29.04. Ich hab noch einen Monat und neun Tage.
Was ist da jetzt überhaupt passiert? Also du wolltest eigentlich ein Sidekick
sein und jetzt bist du irgendwie die Hauptattraktion.
Also okay, ich glaube Folgendes ist passiert.
Ich will jetzt ein bisschen Erwartungshaltung hier aufbauen.
Du hast einfach nicht genug Druck in deinem Leben, verstehst du?
Du musst jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen einen drauflegen.
Also es gibt ja Funfacts, hatte ich glaube ich erzählt.
Tägliche,
Täglicher satirischer, komödiantischer Blick auf Nachrichten.
Aus dem Kreise von vielen Comedians, unter anderem Marc-Uwe Kling und Sarah
Brosetti, der es glaube ich so ein bisschen losgetreten haben und aber sehr,
sehr viele auch wirklich bekannte Leute, die auch richtig begnadete Leute hier
mitmachen. Heinz Strunk.
Heinz Strunkmann. Da freue ich mich schon so unglaublich drauf.
In, was war das? Hamburg, München, Berlin und Köln und Wahrscheinlich gibt es noch eine Stadt.
Und,
dann gibt es die Montag, Dienstag, Mittwoch, Donnerstag Sendung,
die sind immer alle live und Freitag wird aber nicht aufgezeichnet,
sondern am Freitag gibt es immer so einen long,
so einen deep dive, nicht mehr tagesaktuell, wo dann quasi die Amateure,
die nicht professionelle Comedians sind, sondern die halt davor geschult werden
müssen und so weiter, die ja auch eigentlich gar nicht witzig sind. So wie ich.
Die kommen dann da mit rein, weil man davon ausgeht, deren Aufzeichnung machen
wir am Donnerstag mit jemand anders, für den die Leute kommen.
Und dann sagt man, du bist jetzt Vorprogramm und dann haben wir die Aufzeichnung für Freitag.
Und das war eigentlich geplant.
Dass ich eben am Donnerstags Vorprogramm von irgendjemandem bin, der da Leute hat.
Aber du wusstest nicht von wem.
Ich glaube, mir wurde das gesagt und dann habe ich aber, als der letzte Sendung
habe ich es ja irgendwie auch schon gesucht und nicht gefunden.
Da deutete sich das schon an, dass da irgendwas nicht stimmt und dann kriegte ich halt den,
so einen Anruf ja Mensch hier Tickets mit Linus Neumann hab ich gesehen ich
hol mal eins, ich sag was hast du gesehen? nein, ich bin da,
also es war so nicht vereinbart.
Läuft ja super und jetzt, was machen wir da jetzt?
Ja weiß ich nicht es.
Musste noch witzig werden bis dahin.
Bis dahin muss ich witzig werden Ja.
Also ich meine...
Ich habe jetzt nicht alle Videos gesehen. Es waren jetzt auch nicht alle unbedingt
so witzig. Also du musst jetzt auch nicht so witzig sein.
Du kannst auch todernstig da hinstellen in LNP-Manier und dann einfach erzählen.
Ja, aber das ist ja Funfact, nicht Faktab.
Ja. Da bist du jetzt in der Falle. Ich kann dich natürlich noch ein bisschen
coachen, wenn du willst.
Ja? Du könntest mal ein Witzeschreiber werden. Ich brauche einen Witzeschreiber.
Nee, ich brauche wirklich einen Witzeschreiber.
Naja, ist die Frage. was du machen willst, willst du, ich meine,
du könntest natürlich auch einfach das vertrauen, das würde ich dir ja primär
jetzt mal raten, ich würde ja immer auf das vertrauen, was du am besten kannst
und das ist ja so spontan lustig sein.
Ja, hab ich ja auch gesagt, aber das ist ja so eine Nachrichtensendung.
Ja, so ziehst du den Abend halt auf. Du gehst halt hin und erzählst erstmal,
du bist überhaupt nicht lustig und du musst das jetzt mit allen zusammen.
Ja, aber das macht Nico Semsrott schon.
Ja, aber der ist ja nicht lustig. Also der ist ja bewusst nicht lustig.
Ja, also da muss man irgendwie das Publikum beteiligen.
Da müssen die halt irgendwas reinwerfen und dann musst du dich in die Situation
bringen, dass du reagieren musst. Und dann läuft das.
Ja, also funktioniert das halt nicht. Also es ist so, die haben es auch geschafft
mit Luisa Neubauer, ist jetzt auch kein Comedian.
Das war schon auch in Ordnung. Aber ich will auch nicht wissen,
wie die geschwitzt haben muss davor.
Also ich weiß ja, ich kenne sie zumindest nicht als Entertainerin.
Als Entertainerin in einem Nachrichten-Style-Format.
Da musst du den Fun in den Facts finden.
Ja. Der war auf jeden Fall gemein.
Aber hast du denn schon ein Thema?
Nee. Auf die E-Mail muss ich nur antworten. Nichts hab ich. Ich hab einfach
nur eine E-Mail, du bist dann dran. Hier werden Tickets verkauft,
ich dir deinen Namen drauf frag.
Und ich hab auch nicht Bescheid gesagt.
Ja, okay. Also ich meine, das ist ja eine Ansage.
Also ich ich sag ja immer, wenn man nix zu erzählen hat, weil ich besser halt.
Aber also was mir, was zum Glück nicht, also deswegen hab ich mir das auch so
zusammengereimt, ja, weil es also ich muss zumindest nicht den ganzen Abend gestalten.
Also Funfacts, es ist ja so, das sollte ich vielleicht noch dazu sagen.
Wenn da jetzt steht Funfacts mit was weiß ich, Luisa Neubauer und Marc-Uwe Kling
oder was, Da muss die Luisa nur die Viertelstunde hinter sich bringen,
die die Funfacts-Sendung ist und den Rest des Abends gibt es dann eben ein Hauptprogramm.
Oder wenn da jetzt zum Beispiel Funfacts mit Heinz Strunk ist,
dann würde ich davon ausgehen, dass der Heinz Strunk eine Viertelstunde Funfacts
macht und wenn er dann noch Bock hat, dann gestaltet er den Abend noch ein bisschen weiter.
Und du musst den ganzen Abend gestalten.
Dann muss ich wirklich nochmal mit denen reden. Hier steht, den ganzen großen
Rest des Abends gibt es eine Mixshow der Extraklasse zu sehen.
Mit anderen Worten, die haben noch keine Ahnung.
Oder sagen es zumindest nicht.
Oder sagen es mir nicht.
Also wenn du wie Harald Schmidt so einen Sidekick brauchst, der von der Seite,
so ein paar Sprüche reinklopft.
Du bist doch immer ein Manuel Andrak.
Dann kann ich das machen. Wenn dir das weiterhilft, dann musst du halt was einfallen lassen.
Ja, ich hab nur ganz Zeit mir was einfallen zu lassen.
Tja. Ja Leute, ne? Schreibt's in die Kommentare.
Was wollt ihr wählen? Welchen Funfact soll ich erzählen? Wusstet ihr,
dass ein Regenwurm drei Därme hat?
Oder wir machen das mit KI, ja? Verstehst du? Wir schmeißen da einfach alle
Dokumente rein, alle Transkripte von Logbuch und Netzpolitik. Hier ist der Humor.
Das ist das Themenspektrum.
Finde in 548 Sendungen bitte die Funfacts. Kommen wir auf eine Viertelstunde? Nein?
Also das wäre natürlich auch kreativ, wenn du das so aufziehst,
dass sozusagen die ganze Sendung vollständig AI orchestriert wurde von dir.
Also nicht so im Sinne von... Das ist wirklich eine Drohung, ja?
Guck mal, dann steht da irgendwie hier, das Bild einfach genommen aus der Wikipedia,
CC, also Amsau ist alles richtig, aber CC bei alles.
Und dann steht so, den ganzen Rest des Abends gilt eine Mixshow der Extraklasse
und dann in Fett. Funfacts wird aufgezeichnet.
So, Linus, wird aufgezeichnet, ne?
No pressure.
You've got one shot.
Ja, bin ich mal gespannt. In dem Theater war ich auch noch nicht.
Und eine Woche vorher sind dann zum Beispiel hier Raoul Krauthausen,
Anne Broer, Hilka, die ganzen großen Namen, ja?
Das ist sehr unterhaltsam. Aber das ist auch eine Herausforderung.
Ja, das ist eine Herausforderung.
Ich würde es modern machen. Ich meine, das müsste ja sowieso das Thema sein.
Wenn ich mir das sonstige Themenspektrum hier anschaue, dann ist ja so KI noch
überhaupt gar nicht dabei. Es ist alles so politisch und so.
Atomkraft, hier Freiheit, Arbeitslose.
Jetzt kommt irgendwie der Linus, der ist ja mehr so der Techniker.
Da musst du natürlich dann diese Problematik machen.
Das heißt, so, KI Dystopie 3000,
Das ist ja auf jeden Fall schon mal Ja, ich meine, da ist ja auch viel Humor
drin, ne, in diesem ganzen KI-Thema, also, weil alle wissen ja um Halluzinationen
und Auswüchse Könnte auch.
Einfach ein bisschen halluzinieren.
Ja.
Du könntest.
Halluzinieren mit Linus Neumann.
Guck doch mal eben in die Flasche, wie spät das ist Naja.
Also ich finde, das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Ansatz,
über den man nachdenken kann und das kann auf jeden Fall ein sehr unterhaltsamer Abend werden.
Also dann auch gezielt mit der KI zu spielen. Du kannst natürlich dann auch
mit einer KI dich unterhalten, so wie das jetzt hier Bernie Sanders gerade gemacht
hat. Das war natürlich die andere Variante.
Eigentlich.
Gibt es gerade so ein Video, kannst du mal anschauen.
Ich kenne nur das Interview von The Onion mit Sam Altman. Das ist gelungen, ja.
Aber das war wahrscheinlich nicht echt. Bernie Sanders hat sich ja wirklich mit der AI unterhalten.
Und wer hat gewonnen? Chuck Norris.
Naja, es war nicht wirklich ein Wettbewerb. Also ich glaube,
Bernie Sanders hat gewonnen.
Naja, wir mussten es halt Linus Way machen.
Ja, ich bin mal gespannt. Also ich versuch's. Und wenn wir beim Scheitern...
Dann machen wir da einfach LNP. Mehr gibt's nicht.
Also das hat Mastodon schon nahegelegt.
Was? Echt? Mastodon hat das nahegelegt. Naja, also das muss halt ein Spezial sein.
Und ich würde sagen, AI ist genau das Thema.
Da hast du eine Menge beizutragen und da kann man sich auf jeden Fall ein paar
lustige Sachen einfallen lassen und das ist auch unterhaltsam.
Das mögen die Leute, das ist ein Thema, da regt man sich gerne drüber auf.
Aber hier dieses Sam-Oltman-Interview, ne? Was ist denn das Problem,
was sagst du zu den Menschen, die Angst haben, dass AI ihnen den Job wegnimmt?
Antwort, ob von einem Computer oder von einem Chinesen, dein Job war immer dafür
da weggenommen zu werden.
Welchen Sinn werden Menschen stiften, wenn KI jeden Aspekt unseres Lebens dominiert?
Dann sagt er, Menschen waren immer und werden immer wichtig sein, um Werbung zu gucken.
Das ist wirklich...
Da ist auf jeden Fall was zu holen. Ansonsten hast du ja noch die Möglichkeit...
Warte, das ist auch nur das Schöne. Why did you decide to devote your life to AI?
I just saw so much suffering in the world that needed to be automated.
Das ist wirklich ein Wunderschöner.
Achso, es gibt noch einen anderen Termin.
Ja, da kannst du üben. Da kannst du vielleicht da hinfahren.
Nee, der ist danach.
Ach, das ist danach.
Die Tage der digitalen Freiheit in Tübingen vom 15.
Bis 17. Mai 2026. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ist das da, wo der,
Boris Palmer ist?
Ja, genau das ist das.
Könnt ihr euch den mal angucken.
Ist auch sehr gehaltsam.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der da eingeladen ist. Aber also die Tage der digitalen Freiheit
in Tübingen an der Westspitze.
Es ist das fünfte Mal, dass das stattfindet unter dem Hashtag Raute TDF5 und
das Motto ist Freiräume verschlüsseln.
Es geht um digitale Freiheit, Datenschutz, Netzpolitik und Technik,
Workshops, Diskussionen und natürlich ist die Idee zu vernetzen,
sich auszutauschen und einen Raum für Kreativität zu bieten.
Spezifisch richtet sich das nicht nur an das Chaos, also Mitglieder,
Freundinnen und Freunde des Chaos Computer Clubs, sondern an alle,
die einem Leben in Freiheit und Selbstbestimmung in der digitalen Gesellschaft
immer noch Interesse schenken.
Kostenloser Eintritt, kann man da natürlich auch gerne was spenden.
Man kann, glaube ich, auch noch Programm einreichen.
Ja, es gibt noch den CFP, der ist auch bei uns in den in den Shownotes verlinkt.
Dann könnt ihr da eine Einreichung machen.
Man könnte da hingehen.
Was gibt es noch? Vorbereitung, Veranstaltung, genau. Fünfter,
ach das ist das Himmelfahrtwochenende.
Guck dir das an. Der 15. ist Christi Himmelfahrt. Da könnt ihr richtig schön
mit dem Bollerwagen, Bollerwagen, Musik, Kiste Bier.
Oh, guck mal hier. Performances und Installationen könnt ihr auch einreichen.
Also Kunst, Kreativität und Schönheit. Raum, Gebühnen, Projektraum, Hackcenter.
Und ja, Kunstprojekte. Das ist schon alles sehr spannend.
Und die Helferinnen heißen da nicht Engel, sondern Elfen.
Oh.
Ja. Neben den Inhalten lebt das Event auch wir kennen den Begriff aus dem An.
Okay. Hauptsache man kriegt den danach auch wieder weg.
Elfen ist ein Begriff, den man nicht mehr verwenden darf. Aber er wurde in manchen
Kontexten, bevor jetzt der...
Den darf man nicht mehr verwenden, ich fand den super.
Ist auch ein sehr guter Begriff. Also eine Elfe...
Nein, das erklären wir jetzt nicht.
Das müssen wir erklären.
Was? Ist das nicht Geheimwissen?
Im Elfenheim gibt es Mineralwasser und Snacks.
Das Elfen-System ist wunderbar. Dort kannst du dich als Elfe registrieren.
Super.
Das ist auch ein Elfen-System.
Das erklären wir jetzt nicht.
Das müssen wir erklären.
Okay, das musst du aber ohne.
Erklär mir die nächsten Sendung.
Ihr ratet jetzt erstmal.
Ihr könnt in den Kommentaren erraten, was denn so eine Elfe ist.
Ja, genau. Warum wir das jetzt lustig finden.
Ja, müssen wir auch wirklich dran denken.
Okay. Okay, gut, dann machen wir.
Ich registriere mich schon mal.
Ich mach Mittwoch bis Freitag den Tagplatz.
Das kann aber lange dauern. Oh Mann.
Ich glaub, die Sendung ist jetzt zum Ende gekommen.
Ich hätte vielleicht auch noch ein paar Elfen, die kann ich da mal entschicken.
Ja, Leute, das war's. Erstmal wieder von uns. Hat ja nur drei Wochen gedauert.
Wir bemühen uns, dass es nicht wieder so lange dauert.
Noch ein bisschen in den Timber 11.
Komm, wir winken jetzt mal. Tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.
Bis bald.
Tschüss.